people say Brennan I'm scared to start
my dream I'm like you're not scared to
start your dream you're embarrassed to
be seen starting small big difference
it's not about the dream that's freaking
you out it's about how you're gonna feel
Chasing the Dream It's about how you're
going to be perceived Chasing the Dream
It's about how you fear at night it
won't turn out the way you wanted it's
not about the dream it's about how
you're processing how it will feel
Chasing the Dream and once you figure
that out you see that you can rewire
yourself you can teach yourself to think
differently about the journey and the
process because look no matter how small
you start start something that matters
start something that brings your life
back you know start something that makes
your heart feel full start something
that does scare you allow that fear
allow that worry allow that anxiety a
little bit because that's just saying
you're growing you're learning you're
changing you're getting going but let's
be very clear most people what they're
really scared about is being embarrassed
well I don't know if I quit my job and I
start this thing what do my co-workers
think when I do that I don't know if I
start this what are my friends gonna say
when they see me playing small and not
doing big things because every big
project starts with small little tasks
that don't look sexy oh what's what's
everyone think about me that I chose
this route when the other thing was over
here and that was a better choice what
people are scared about is being
rejected or more being embarrassed I
tell people all the time don't be
embarrassed to start small I I think
about when I started doing videos you
know it wasn't you know we're 200
million video views now we I mean tell
you what we when I started I was okay
with the fact that it was like 10 people
watching my videos you know nine of them
was my mom on a different browser's
probably hitting refresh to make me feel
better about myself you know like I
accepted the fact that starting small
was part of the game instead of
bemoaning that I honored that process I
said that is part of it being small in a
big pond with big fish is part of the
game and only until you keep playing
keep moving keep building do you ever
become one of the big fish you have to
be okay with being small and so if you
start your Channel or you start your
thing and only 100 people watch it hey
that's a hundred people who heard your
message that's a hundred people who you
help that's 100 people who you change
your mindset for that's a hundred people
who let you do your own thing and watch
and even if they were haters at least
you started penetrating their mind get
in the game never be embarrassed about
starting small or Scrappy or crappy
because that's part of the journey it's
supposed to be that way so don't fear it
acknowledge that's part of it I'm gonna
honor that let's go think big
act small think big have a big goal Big
Dreams big desires big mission big big
Vision You're Gonna Change the World
think big let's go we love that as
entrepreneurs right let's think big and
change the world and act small
in that you got to do something
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum
where what most people do is if you're
just thinking big and feel like you have
to act big from the start
then nothing ever ends up happening and
that big goal dies within you
we are afraid of taking the first step
we are afraid of building momentum we
are afraid of people seeing us and
nobody's seen us I just finished this
seven day challenge uh and built to
serve helping people become thought
leaders and people are afraid of people
watching their content and what their
what those people are going to say and
they're equally afraid of nobody
watching their content so you're afraid
of somebody seeing what you're doing and
judging you and you're also afraid of
people not seeing what you're doing and
you're creating an obscurity so you're
afraid of being seen and not being seen
at the exact same time is it any wonder
why you're not creating is there any
wonder why you're not making is there
any wonder why you're stuck and just
planning and strategizing and making the
the perfect thing happen before
something ever happens is it ever any
wonder why if you want to start a
YouTube channel you're still stuck on
what the opening sentence is going to be
and what microphone you're going to use
and what camera and what lighting and
what the background and how your hair is
going to look in your wardrobe and is
there any wonder why you're still stuck
on that instead of just creating
because we're afraid we're afraid of
being seen and we're afraid of not being
seen at the same time and so we've
convinced ourselves why we can't do
something with with you know rational
logical reasons that we believe
are really you're just not making
content you're just not making progress
you're just not having the conversations
you need to have you're just not
building the business that you should be
building right whatever the thing is
it's just at the end of the day it's
just fear and the thing that's missing
is momentum
how I encourage people to get through it
is what I tell myself I expect to suck
at the beginning
whatever you do
when it's your first time expect to suck
right just expect to suck at the start
why do you think you're going to be
amazing the first time you go and create
something you're not it's gonna suck
it's it's not gonna be very good like
even objectively it's not gonna be very
good probably
but that's okay doesn't mean you suck as
a person
I think it's amazing I think the fact
that you're willing to try is an
inspiration and so whenever you're first
getting started off when you have
expectations and then you don't meet
those expectations in this Gap this is
the gap that prevents you from taking
further action
how many times have you tried to do
something you got started you weren't
getting results like you thought you
would and you just quit right away how
many times have you
recorded a video watched it back were
completely embarrassed by yourself and
then never posted it and never launch
your channel there's been people who
I've done interviews with as their first
guest on their podcast or YouTube show
or Instagram whatever and then they
never post it
they never posted because they are too
embarrassed to even launch the show and
it was it was even a decent a decent
interview
but the insecurities and the fears and
the doubts creep in and so they don't
they don't post it they don't do
anything about it where you just need to
expect the suck at the beginning
just expect to suck expected to be
terrible and that gives you the freedom
to go off and create because like
anything else whatever it is you want to
do you want to be a YouTube Creator you
want to be an entrepreneur you want to
be a coach an author a speaker whatever
it is that that your business is
it's all doable it's just a skill that
you need to learn there's a bunch of
skills that you need to pick up and
learn and like any other skill you can
learn it of course you can learn it
you can pick up any skill
but you don't have the skill right now
and so don't overly judge yourself for
not having the skill and not being good
enough as a human being just because you
don't have the skill set yet
right this isn't you're not good enough
as a human it's you're not good enough
at this specific skill set yet that when
you can figure that thing out and get
the training education experience then
you can go and accomplish the goal of
course
but we overly judge ourselves and then
we don't build momentum
one of my movie makers
uh his name is Michael he's he's an
amazing human he
wanted to start making content want to
start making videos wanted to start
doing interviews and he was he was
afraid of
asking people to be on the show and him
being the interview were he was fine
being an interviewee when people were
asking him questions but he didn't want
to be the interviewer and was afraid to
ask people questions and so we had a
discussion and we came up with a concept
where it was
his show called his show is called
empowering conversations with a disabled
man so he's disabled he wants to help
reduce the stigma around people with
disabilities he wants to have open
conversations he wants to help people
who are disabled find Hope and
inspiration and power and he also wants
to
educate able-bodied people to how to how
to help support cherish their disabled
friends or the community and so we came
up with a concept of empowering
conversations with a disabled man and he
launched his first live interview where
he was having the conversation he had a
guest come on and he was doing an
interview and
it was the idea to action that made all
the difference because he'd been
thinking about doing a show and thinking
about making content and you know being
too afraid and being stuck in his head
like all of us do myself included all of
us do
and to his credit the thing that that
I did not do at his stage in this career
was he just went off and did it he just
okay you know what here's an idea I'm
gonna do something about it I'm gonna do
something about it I'm gonna get started
and he had his first one I asked him how
he did he said it was so much fun it was
so great it was so amazing and now he
scheduled the second one he's gonna keep
doing more it's a great win and that it
worked out now if he keeps going on this
show you know say he does 100 episodes
of this show he's gonna look back on his
first video and realize oh my gosh I was
so bad at the beginning right but look
at the journey look at the growth
same thing for you whatever you're
starting off doing and just expect to
suck at the beginning expect to suck
expect no results expect nobody to see
it expect it to be terrible and tomorrow
you're going to keep going you can make
it a little bit better and a little bit
better a little bit better and when you
look back on 10 days 20 days 50 days 100
days you'll come back and say holy cow
I'm really getting better why because
you developed a skill you were you were
still the same awesome human now you're
developing the skill set to actually get
better at the thing that you want to do
makes all the difference the only thing
you're missing is momentum so just
repeat yourself repeat to yourself
the only thing I'm missing is momentum
the only thing you're missing is
momentum you've got the heart the care
the passion the desire to serve the
vision the just the soul to help you've
got all that you know you can help
all you're missing is momentum you're
just not doing enough and that's not
that's not a beat down to say judge
yourself and you suck again as a person
and you should be doing more don't do
that
but take the time that you spend
criticizing yourself and judging
yourself for not being good enough and
use that energy to then just go make
something and expect to suck so a couple
things that helped me that that that
gives me the permission to
to start so it's not a high bar it's a
it's there is no bar
there is the virus solo that there is no
bar and that gives you permission to
just start and to create the momentum
you're looking for the other thing that
I find really helps me is
just trust that great ideas flow through
you
whether whether it's belief in self
whether it's belief in something higher
but just trust a good ideas flow through
you that if
an idea comes you for something you want
to do trust it is a good idea trust that
that is the right idea for you that you
should do it that you should take action
on it and that it's going to serve if
you're in a positive mindset right if
you're if you're in a negative mindset
then then it's good to sleep on your
ideas right if you're in a jealous
mindset or hateful mindset or a rageful
mindset then the ideas that come to you
are probably not the right ideas for you
but if you're in a powering empowering
inspiring positive optimistic mindset
then the ideas that come to you are the
right ones for you and just trust that
those are the right ideas and do
something on it and shortcut your brain
because as soon as your brain takes over
it's gonna be like oh okay but you don't
know how to do this and that and then
here's another problem and more
restrictions and you you know okay so
what happens default okay let's go
default to planning and researching and
we'll keep asking questions and we'll
keep him in high and then you know next
week I'll do something and then next
week comes and you haven't done it yet
right so when an idea comes to you you
find the smallest possible way to get
started on it today don't make it some
big giant thing that now you need a
million dollars in venture capital and a
huge team to accomplish
the only thing you're missing is
momentum right
so trust that great ideas flow through
you great ideas flow through you
you're here to do so much more
and take that kernel of an idea and do
something
whatever the smallest possible simplest
thing is to just build some kind of
momentum for it
to see how much did you love it how much
do you want to go back and do it
without having to pressure on it having
to be the perfect thing the next big
thing the only thing that matters
because that's what keeps you stuck
slow
knowing that you're capable of more but
too afraid to act
great ideas flow through you and the
only thing you're missing is momentum
let's go
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
you must establish the Rhythm
of the teams
you've got to establish the Rhythm and
what that means is let's say you're
running an organization the rhythm of
the organization results in in two ways
when you think about it there's an
internal Rhythm the way that you meet
the way that you set goals the the
rhythm of planning your quarter or your
okrs your kpis it's all the internal
Rhythm of the things that you do to
function and run the business right
then there's the external Rhythm that is
your release Rhythm that is your launch
Rhythm that's your marketing Rhythm
that's the public-facing publicity
Rhythm it's what the world sees of you
now those two rhythms are sometimes
different they're different in
organizationally they're different in
families they're different in how you
might run a a new team versus an uh an
established team
but it's so important that you as the
leader take that on the Helm of like oh
what does that need to look like and you
won't know unfortunately until you
practice principle number one people
support what they create
I'll give an example in in my company
right now we're we're added a whole
bunch of new people and we're still
trying to figure out okay what's this
new rhythm going to look like and so the
new team has to come in and see the
Rhythm we're doing now and then we've
got to adjust and pivot to the new team
to establish the Norms you all know this
from storm and forming and norming and
team research experience well our our
job is to figure out okay what should
that Rhythm be on across the company
like your All Hands meetings and
processes to what each team or each
organizational unit does or how you're
going to improve families have to do
this too so you're a parent okay what's
your family Rhythm what do you do Monday
through Sundays what are your rituals
what are those time slots that you're
going to repeat you might have a rhythm
that you have with your partner or
spouse you go out of date nights on
Fridays right or you might have a rhythm
that you have with this child versus
that child in order to create that
connection with them
everything has to be thought of in terms
of a rhythm or a ritual or a patterned
calendar slot in order for everyone to
feel like oh we're moving in unison here
When leaders don't establish or work to
establish with their teams or their
culture or their families what the
rhythm is going to be Everything feels
random all the time everything feels
like we're fighting fires fighting
fighting it always feels like we're
fighting Fighters we're in emergency
mode and we're going to burn out
and so I see this all the time and it's
the hardest part because you as a leader
often don't know what the Rhythm needs
to be yet it has to happen in motion
which is why it's so important to be a
good listener
so many leaders come into new companies
and when they come into new companies
you know I recently uh I think was last
it was two quarters ago helped the CEO
transition into a company where they had
12 000 employees and I got brought in by
the board because
he was in trouble and so God brought in
his 360 evaluations from the whole team
he'd only been there like six months
everyone hated the guy and I couldn't
like it took a while to figure out very
likable emotionally intelligent fun
smart business person and I'm like what
what is going on
and what I found out was when he came
into the company
he just he said well this is this has to
be our Rhythm here's our quarterly goals
this is our yearly goals this is how we
meet and just impose the Rhythm on an
existing team they weren't ready for
that and so it was like a revolt and for
them they got used to doing something
this whole thing changed everything it
was too fast
and if you're an organizational leader
you know that that's super hard it
always happens every company goes
through it Transitions and leadership
are always difficult always challenging
but your job is to be aware of that
and your job if you're if you're the
person who has that Vision decision you
have to work really hard to establish
that normal Rhythm normal meeting
Cadence normal way about trying to
achieve a goal normal way of managing a
project normal way of meeting a a
quarterly you know stretch you you have
to establish that and you're probably
going to need help with it this is a
great distinction between where
leadership and management diverge
leaders work with managers to establish
that people support what they create to
establish that Rhythm and often the
leader doesn't actually manage the
Rhythm they help set it up they agree to
it they go and then there's project
managers there's mid-level managers
there's other people who are going to
make sure that that Rhythm happens right
same thing might happen to your family
you might say okay we're all going to do
this but you might not be the person who
always makes that thing happen you might
be like you might have some support you
might have an assistant you might assign
the rhythm of the kids to the older kid
right that you hear that there's an
assignment happening there but you need
to be aware of it and ensure that rhythm
is happening with great Energy number
one
is my friend hat which is so important
uh this is where when I'm having a bad
day I always say okay
I was coaching my absolute dearest best
friend in the world who just went
through the same day what would I
suggest that they do next
not how would I change your life not
some big high fluent stuff like what
would I suggest that person they do like
literally next
in that situation they're in would it be
you know what you really need to call
your mom you know what you you need to
call that person apologize you know what
you need to send that email you know
what you need to do is take this but
what would I tell my absolute best most
adored friend to do as their very next
step not the whole plan just what's one
thing I would tell my absolute best
dearest friend I asked myself this
question probably two three times a week
right because I'll get frustrated by
something something'll piss me off or
I'll be bummed that something crashed
and burned I'll be okay
if my best friend just went through that
exact same thing what would I say they
should do first and of course once I
think of what they should do first then
the next step comes and the next step
and the next step meaning kind of coach
and advise yourself from a third party
standpoint I know you probably know you
should do that but here's the way that I
make it stick
I write the letter
this means I sit down with a blank piece
of paper and I write the letter to
myself from the best friend's
perspective dear Brendan you're really
ugly and stupid but you're my best
friend so buddy here's what I recommend
you do about the situation that you're
in here's how I think you should think
about it here's what I recommend that
you should do
and I literally write the letter to
myself from the perspective of my best
friend does that make sense that's what
I call putting on my friend hat and I
write the letter dear Brendan
and sometimes it's just I write it it's
super short it's on a little note card I
write like 10 sentences other times man
I gotta dig deep and that thing becomes
like a four-page letter to myself you
know and we know from psychology is
specifically dealing with therapy and
Trauma that if you will write yourself a
letter it does significantly change your
emotional well-being and writing it from
this perspective as a friend has I have
found made my letters much more
compassionate much more thoughtful much
more positive so I just put my friend
hat on I write myself a little letter
dude if you
all the time you gotta change how you
look at the world yes there's a lot in
the news that can piss you off yes
there's a lot going on that causes
outrage all day long on Twitter or
social media somewhere but if that's
your sole Focus no wonder you're upset
all the time lots of people are angry
right now because of the news or
something chaotic or terrible or
something they don't agree with is
happening in the world but that's not
new
there's always chaos there's always
turmoil there's always bad things happen
in the world but if that's your focus no
wonder you're having that anxiety and
that frustration and that anger all the
time you got to change both your focus
and how you're reacting to things when
you do see it so first let's work on
your focus you know our as much as
you're angry all the time are you also
noticing the beauty of this world I mean
the odds that you're even alive and
having your breath is something to
connect to every single morning to have
reverence for your life in the morning
to wake up you know one of my late
mentors was Wayne Dyer an amazing
amazing teacher and he always talked
about how he woke up he rolled over he
put his feet on the ground and he said
thank you
thank you thank you he was grateful for
his day and he began that way and I
think so many people right now they kind
of roll up in bed and they're like and
they grab their freaking phone and they
start going through the news on social
media and what are they queuing
immediately I'm cueing stress chaos
turmoil clickables you know it's like
clickbait click click clickbait no
wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately right
off the beginning of the day in all the
turmoil of the world put the dang phone
down get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your A game that day so you can focus on
that instead of like this in bed that
will change how you start your day and
then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time they're also in
Outrage all the time because they're
focusing on the problem all the time and
they're bemoaning the problem they're
calling out the problem complaining
about the problem judging criticizing
getting upset all the time a ton of
people who stay in anger all the time
are failing to be solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem outrage
outrage outrage but listen when you
become a solution-based person you say
okay I actually want to do something
about this problem and you start taking
positive steps to at least address it or
to participate suddenly that anger goes
into a new fire and that fire is called
enthusiasm it is easy to switch anger
into enthusiasm when you become solution
based as a mindset when you say okay I
don't like this let me do something let
me let me call somebody let me take this
action let me write that letter let me
send that email let me get my friends
together let's go protest let's go get
involved let's participate because
participation turns anger often into
enthusiasm people say Brennan I'm scared
to start my dream I'm like you're not
scared to start your dream you're
embarrassed to be seen starting small
big difference it's not about the dream
that's freaking you out it's about how
you're gonna feel Chasing the Dream It's
about how you're going to be perceived
Chasing the Dream It's about how you
fear at night it won't turn out the way
you wanted it's not about the dream it's
about how you're processing how it will
feel Chasing the Dream and once you
figure that out you see that you can
rewire yourself you can teach yourself
to think differently about the journey
and the process because look you know no
matter how small you start start
something that matters
start something that brings your life
back you know it starts something that
makes your heart feel full start
something that does scare you allow that
fear allow that worry allow that anxiety
a little bit because that's just saying
you're growing you're learning you're
changing you're getting going but let's
be very clear most people what they're
really scared about is being embarrassed
well I don't know if I quit my job and I
start this thing what do my co-workers
think when I do that I don't know if I
start this what are my friends gonna say
when they see me playing small and not
doing big things because every big
project starts with small little tasks
that don't look sexy oh what's it what's
ever going to think about me that I
chose this route when the other thing
was over here and that was a better
choice what people are scared about is
being rejected or more being embarrassed
I tell people all the time don't be
embarrassed to start small I I think
about when I started doing videos you
know it was we're 200 million video
views now we I mean tell you what we
when I started I was okay with the fact
that it was like 10 people watching my
videos you know nine of them was my mom
on a different browser's probably
hitting refresh to make me feel better
about myself you know like I accepted
the fact that starting small was part of
the game instead of bemoaning that I
honored that process I said that is part
of it being small in a big pond with big
fish is part of the game and only until
you keep playing keep moving keep
building do you ever become one of the
big fish you have to be okay with being
small and so if you start your Channel
or you start your thing and only 100
people watch it hey that's a hundred
people who heard your message that's a
hundred people who you help that's 100
people who you change your mindset for
that's a hundred people who let you do
your own thing and watch and even if
they were haters at least you started
penetrating their mind get in the game
never be embarrassed about starting
small or Scrappy or crappy because
that's part of the journey it's supposed
to be that way so don't fear it
acknowledge that's part of it I'm gonna
honor that let's go I was a
maybe 24 25 year old man and I was a
member of Kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know Kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or Lions Club
um it's a it's a a it's a non-profit
organization that's dedicated towards
service in in the community and I was in
Kiwanis and I was the youngest one hands
down like in in the room we'd get
together every single month on a Tuesday
and we have lunch and we'd have a
speaker in and then we talk about a
volunteer project we were going to do
that month and that was kind of how it
went in Kiwanis for me and so I but in
my room I was 24 25 in the room every
Tuesday
um when we got together everyone else
was older I mean they were like 50s and
60s and 70s older when I was 20 I was
the youngest person in the room every
single time and
I remember I was having a particularly
a challenging time because I was
thinking about quitting my job but I was
scared because I didn't I hadn't saved
any money
um I didn't know exactly what I wanted
to do I just knew that I I knew that the
job wasn't the thing at the time
but I didn't know what it was and so I
was scared to make the leap and I was
just I was just kind of struggling with
some existential stuff because you know
I had been four or five years I hadn't
had a girlfriend and it was just
frustrating I was like dating but I
wasn't able I just wasn't making real
connections on when I was dating and I
was just unhappy in that part of my life
I didn't know what I was doing my career
I didn't have a significant relationship
I was like oh man I'm just kind of
didn't feel good
and so I was having a really down day
on that particular Tuesday and I went in
and I was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the Just One of the
awesome kowanians that who was there and
he was
um I think he was probably 59 six years
old he was in banking
um very successful wealthy guy happy hap
just he was like a happy-go-lucky
Grandpa type you know just a good dude
and I'm just kind of listing off to him
all these things that suck you know and
he says what are you doing about it and
I said well you know I
you know and he says well I bet and he
said I bet I know what's going on he's
you're going home you're probably
watching too much TV drinking too much
beer and sitting alone too often or
you're going out and not having any fun
and we're just talking my mode was yeah
I kind of I go inside so I kind of pull
away from people when I'm unhappy and so
I was like yeah I kind of pull away and
I'm in my house and he says why I know
how to solve a problem
I said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
buy tickets what do you mean buy tickets
he goes I want you to open up the paper
remember the papers so he's I want you
to open up the paper and he goes I want
you to see what's going on in your town
and I want you to buy tickets to
whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends is it is there a symphony
coming to town buy tickets is there a
ballet buy tickets is there a uh an art
museum buy tickets is there he said is
there a concert buy tickets
and I said what do you mean it's buy
tickets I want you to buy one two three
four tickets and I want you to take your
friends and I just want you to go I want
you to buy tickets and I want you to go
and I'm like what hell does this have to
do with anything I'm even talking about
he goes just buy the tickets and come
back next month tell me about the
tickets and I'm like no and he literally
pulls out his wallet and I'll never
forget he sets down three 100 dollar
bills and he goes
buy the tickets here's the money and I'm
like what are you even I was literally
so frustrated it's a long story short
I'll try to keep it shorter but so I
bought tickets I got like a symphony
ticket I uh got a there's like a dance
troupe in town or something weird
there's a Dave Matthews concert
and what else is there's one other thing
I can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets I
went with one or two or three friends
and
went to them and the second I remember
even I remember
the opening act for the Dave Matthews
Band started and I was like
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so I was down and out and he got me
out and about and then with you with
your friends and you're socializing and
it's in a new environment and things are
happening and my mind just started
turning on again I started getting all
these ideas and these dreams that I
don't know where they were they weren't
in my room they weren't in my bed these
ideas and dreams they weren't happening
in my journal the the the ideas and
dreams they weren't happening in my my
daily planner it was like I was stuck
there so he moved me over here have you
ever been like at a ballet or a symphony
in Orchestra and you're just sitting
there and all of a sudden you feel
amazing
like the music hits you this idea comes
in and you walk out and you feel amazing
have you ever gone to a Broadway show
you went in and you were frustrated and
freaked out because all the horrible New
York traffic and all of a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
Broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now no problem is
gonna slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to the seminar buy tickets
to the event buy tickets to the art
museum the ballet buy tickets and I mean
if you're down and out and your life
sucks right now go buy tickets for the
next four weeks and I promise you're
gonna be like damn
buy tickets that changed my life
changed my life too and I've learned
ever since then like if I'm down and out
it's like buy tickets what if your
parents don't support you what who cares
if your team doesn't support you who
cares if your friends think you're crazy
who cares if nobody in this world sees
your dream it is not your parents or
your professors or your peers or the
world's job to support your dream that's
your dream that dream was sewed into
your heart that dream was given to you
to nurture to protect to fulfill it's
not somebody else's job so if your
parents don't like your idea you don't
have to live your life to please just
your parents if your friends think
you're crazy it's not your job to make
all your friends think that you're sane
if your professors or the people in your
community think oh my gosh you're just
Reckless and crazy and stupid it's not
your job to prove that you're smart to
them your job is to fulfill that heart's
desire your job is to fulfill that part
of you that that is begging you and
pleading you to follow your dreams to
follow your heart to create your thing
so first and foremost don't think that
is everybody else's job to support you
it's not everybody else's job to cheer
you on to give you money to invest in
you to patch you on the back every time
you walk into your house at night and
you did a good job it's okay that other
people have a different vision for
themselves than you do just like you
don't need to judge other people because
you don't like their dreams their
desires or the way they live their life
or do their nine to five
then you shouldn't worry if they judge
yours and that's the first thing I
always tell people is it is not other
people's responsibilities to support you
or to believe in you and I know that you
know when I wrote my first book no one
believed me I quit my nine to five job
and everyone goes you're so crazy to
quit this job who are you to be a writer
you're a dumb kid it's true who was I to
be a writer but I didn't worry what
other people thought or if their
judgment was approval for me to go ahead
in my heart I knew I wanted to write I
wanted to create and that desire was
what I listened to not other people's
judgments or opinions and remember most
other people's opinions are completely
uninformed opinions about you you got to
let go of those things that upset you
three years ago five years ago ten years
ago if you're an adult and you're still
angry and pissed about things that
happen to you in high
you need a therapist and I say that with
all sincerity and all respect if you're
having mental thoughts that are coming
from a place that are literally based 5
10 20 years ago that you just didn't
deal with yet you need help dealing with
it and you need to get yourself a
meditation practice or a therapist or in
some kind of way that you're on a
consistent basis letting things go
here's what I do every Sunday I go okay
what was I pissed about this last week
what really bothered me okay I gotta let
that go
because you can't keep charging into the
next week angry from last week you got
to let it go you got to find a clean
slate for yourself so that your your
soul can expand and can be positive and
can be ambitious and motivated and
serving the next week because listen
anger after anger after anger hatred
after hatred after hatred criticism
after criticism after criticism
rejection after rejection after
rejection outrage after outrage after
outrage it weighs you down
so you've got to change how much of that
you're taking in and you've got to make
sure every single week you're doing some
kind of like mental detox to let that
stuff go and instead of cultivating the
anger cultivate the Gratitude cultivate
the enthusiasm and you can change your
life people all say well Brandon I lost
my motivation I'm like you didn't lose
your motivation you forgot to show up in
the morning look and think and feel what
is it you are fighting for so you just
show up and sometimes you check your
inbox and you look on social media or
you listen to that podcast or even you
do your workout but you're not thinking
and obsessing what is it I'm fighting
for in my life right now or who is it I
am fighting for because if you begin
your day grounded in what you find to be
purposeful meaningful important
fulfilling and you say what is it I'm
fighting for why am i showing up why is
it necessary that I deliver with
Excellence today and you really
emotionally get connected to something
that's the challenge people are losing
their motivation because they're not
emotionally connected to anything
outside of like the outrage on social
media outside of the outrage of the news
oh they're losing that fire inside that
wants to build something create
something deliver something overcome
something so now they're just focused on
everybody else and the real thing is
they didn't lose their motivation they
got distracted two different things
right if you're really connected with
what you are doing and why you are doing
it and who you are doing for
specifically everything changes and
you'll overcome even the distractions
I've written six books now I have been
surrounded by so many critics and so
many judgments you know we have 200
million video views of my views on my
videos online guess what a lot of the
people were haters
but instead of seeing them and getting
angry about it I just see it and it's
like swipe it doesn't affect me anymore
part of maturity is getting that point
where you can see criticism and see
hatred and not make it your own
not make it about your identity to allow
other people's opinions and judgments to
live out there because they're not going
to go away you need to accept that the
criticisms the judgments the hatred it's
not going away you'll probably only hear
more of it as you grow even as you get
more fame or more people liking you or
more people accepting you or you get
promoted people ultimately will support
you as you get momentum but people will
still hate you so if you don't deal with
it now if you don't make a switch in
your mind that says Ah either I'm going
to limit my exposure to them or I'm
going to change how my I react to them
you will always be slave to other
people's opinions and that is not a life
of Freedom that you want to live the
reason people are scared to start their
dream is because they're seeing this big
complex thing they're I mean they're
looking out and it's this huge thing
they see the complexity of the final
vision of the dream and so starting now
is too overwhelming they're not scared
to start the dream they're scared scared
of the feeling of feeling overwhelmed
that's what they're scared of so how do
you deal with that stop thinking you
have to have everything perfect and
complete at the beginning
the finish line is 26 miles ahead what
matters now is step one two three four
the first mile you need to figure out
what is the first mile towards your
dream not what's the finish line look
like of course if you look at the Finish
Line it's intimidating you look at
somebody who already has the business
you want you look at somebody who
already has the car and the dream the
house and the perfect life and they've
done it all already they're 5 10 15 20
years in front of you and it seems so
complexity why should I even start look
how far ahead they are they had more
miles they put more miles in but you
can't compete with their miles you got
to start with your first step right here
right now you go okay I'm gonna be okay
starting small and instead of trying to
in day one have it all complete and take
on all the complexity I'm gonna do one
thing here three goals today three goals
the next day three goals the next day
and I'm gonna get that momentum going
because with that momentum comes more
motivation with that momentum more
learning with that momentum more
progress us but it only begins if you're
okay starting small and taking on little
bites at your dream and not trying to
eat the whole thing all at once because
it will overwhelm you we complete the
world's largest study of high performers
worldwide with data points of over 2
million people from 190 countries around
the world and when we pull then we found
out who those High performers were the
people who had the longest term success
there was no question at all that they
tend to be focusing on one person or
maybe their team or maybe their
financial situation they were focused on
like one or two things for the reason
that they were doing things and it
wasn't like I'm Gonna Change the World
and they had some big you know esoteric
dreamy kind of thing they're like you
know what I gotta make the rent you know
what I gotta buy this new thing you know
what I want to build this team you know
what I want to build this business you
know what I got to get my R out here I'm
fighting for that but they were fighting
for one specific thing maybe two but it
was so special specific for me it would
be live love matter and it'd be
something around those truths like
because at the end of your life what I
found uh you know
it's hard to give perspective this but
for 20 years I've been telling people to
find those questions
and no matter what and I I don't know if
you know this but I volunteered in
hospices for a decade I've been with a
lot of people in their last moments
weeks and months I've been I've been
around a lot of that in my life because
I wanted to see if what I experienced on
that car was what other people
experienced in some ways it was in some
ways at the end we all wanted to know
did I live and how that was and did I
love and did I matter I just knew that
psychologically with familiarity
you know the odds of decreasing anxiety
is extremely high so it's basically like
running a simulation running that
simulation yeah exactly like a pilot
running that simulation over and over
and over if you're a pilot and you run
the simulation and it crashes 50 times
the first 10 you're mortified the last
you know 12 you're on the dials you know
and so I think just running the pattern
over and over visually is really
powerful
the world completely underestimates the
power of visualization
completely
misutilizes the human power of
contemplation
uh
you know the number one thing I say to
my high performance clients is going
through the motions is the death of high
performance
High performers don't go through the
motions yeah I think they're
contemplated they're intentional they're
thoughtful they practice they they want
it to go well and the reason most people
don't do that is because the pressure it
puts a lot of pressure on yourself
but that's what makes people great the
truth is
life will never be joyous unless you
bring the joy
I really feel like that so many people
are waiting to have happiness and
they're just they're waiting to like
well maybe when my boss loosens up I'll
loosen up or you know when when when
when she's vulnerable I'll be vulnerable
or it's like we're waiting for something
I'm like it's not your life will never
be what it is going to be unless you
bring that thing
you know for me I want to be I want to
be more bold in my life
that was one of my goals because I
wasn't that you know I wasn't that guy
who just like go out and do the things I
do now so I made gold like I was like
bold is an intention I said it as an
alarm on my phone
my alarm would go off three times a day
and bold would pop up and I conditioned
myself over seven years to be more bold
which is a big deal for me
um and because I wanted I wanted that I
had to learn how to bring that so
whatever you want in life you got to
bring it camera was super awkward for me
and I was like okay but if I want to
change the world guess what is necessary
communication skills
I'm going to have to learn that
I was not I didn't wasn't raised in a
place I was raised in Montana where men
didn't really communicate except with
looks glances and fists you know so it
was like if a guy lifted it wasn't like
we like we're gesturing right yeah where
I'm from if their hand came up you're
getting punched in the face man that was
it oh uh so I had to learn emotional
intelligence that's a skill uh uh so
communication emotional intelligence
when I got into our business I had to
learn copywriting I know what that was
email marketing I didn't know that I had
to learn coding I don't none of that I
knew what it was but I was always
confident and I think real confidence is
your belief
in your ability to figure things out
I believe in my ability to freak things
out give me enough time energy resources
study books mentors I will figure out
ain't you want me to go to the Moon I'll
figure it out even though I don't have
no idea today I can learn and get
mentors so that's a deep part of my life
High performers have that we all have to
have those things in our business or our
brands or the things that we're being
productive towards that push us that
challenge us if you don't have three or
four of those each year that are your
form of business or productivity
marathons build them back in
build in challenging expressions
for yourself each year build them in we
all need our own Marathon each year
whether that's a true running marathon
or for me this is it for me
and I got eight of these a year
that I build in that make me sharp I
don't need to do them the better use of
my time would just be doing more videos
on the internets
more social media but this
this pushes me this demands Excellence
from me having people in my life who I
can you know when I'm on the road for x
amount of time or I'm dealing with a
super hard client or we're rolling out a
leadership program to a Fortune 50
company or you know I'm doing my first
you know major deal with Oprah Winfrey
Network and I don't know what to do
I am so incredibly fast of asking people
what to do
I'm also incredibly fast in Sharing how
I feel about it being like Oh you know I
feel really awkward about this uh you
know I'm unsure you know I'm having a
lot of self-doubt how would you deal
with it like I'm somebody who expresses
his emotions all the time my freaking
tagline is bring the joy like everybody
knows that why because I want to make
sure people know you're we're going to
create this energy because emotion is
not something you have it is something
you generate
emotion can be an impulse
but feelings is our interpretations of
those impulse over a period of time and
I said I want to feel vibrancy Joy love
connection satisfaction fulfillment in
my life
so I'm going to learn to generate those
emotions how do you learn to generate
the emotions you read psychology how do
you learn to generate the emotions you
try like you're just like I I'm gonna go
we're gonna have date night tonight I'm
gonna make it a fun night
I'm going to make it a fun night I'm
gonna I'm gonna do things to see can I
make people laugh can I make people turn
their lights on I think
the challenge
you have when you're good is that you're
good yeah so you're like I'm doing
pretty good already yeah the better you
get the more expertise development you
get the easier it is to show up and go
through the motions yeah you don't have
to prepare as much you don't have to
practice as much good results whatever
you can do is good enough yeah but what
happens when I perform it eats at them
because they know they got more in the
tank and they're like you know what that
was good but I could have got another
and it's not that they're dissatisfied
we take on that myth in this book High
performers are not dissatisfied so
people who say never be satisfied
they got to look at why they're saying
that because it's not true because High
performers are satisfied they're they're
striving satisfied doesn't mean they're
not striving for the next big thing want
to become better but they're happy High
performers are happier than all of their
peers I mean by significant almost
double digits so it's really significant
um but I think for me
I need to constantly be reminding myself
like okay
what is the reason you need to perform
really well right now
and I need to be more consistent about
that question
um so I set up triggers in my life to do
that you know
um
from every time I stand in line
I have a line trigger I'm door triggers
I have phone triggers you know so when I
stand in line I always say what level am
I right now in terms of my presence and
energy
scale 110. one I suck I'm dead I'm not
even alive not even feeling grateful you
know 10 like I'm Vibra I'm joyous here I
am
um and I rate myself consistently on
that and it just retouches me like the
knee I want to feel it's necessary to be
grateful
I want to feel it's necessary to be
great I want to feel it's necessary to
do my best but you don't get that
without reminders so you got to set up
alarms or triggers or some you know note
cards around that whatever it is it
takes for you to have that but I know
for me raise after the research I didn't
get how
I mean I mean you're talking from every
athlete to every High CEO this is what
they did there and I didn't find this I
you'll see all the questions I asked
them in the book I really had to dial in
their psyche and when we found that I
was like is that a thing that they'd
really that's I mean but they all do I
would say maybe not the most popular
answer go to the fear how are you gonna
look
silly or stupid you're not going to ask
questions
and you're going to end up in the wrong
place and people are like why didn't you
just ask like follow the fear if the
fear says I'm scared I'm look stupid by
asking questions like well let's flip
that because if you don't ask questions
you're definitely going to look stupid
those who learn to endure hardship
struggle challenge difficulty pain grief
vulnerability failure
um regret
that's one side of that coin
if you learn to do that but you also
know on the other side
learn to allow
Joy fulfillment satisfaction a sense of
now hold on hold on I have to stop you
allow is that the word you want to
commit to you said bring I'm going to
build okay build it you have to first
allow it because what most people do is
if on the other side of the coin it's
super etched in
what happens is even when that impulse
comes up to I like this oh no I'm not
supposed to like this so you have a lot
of people who are extremely talented at
the top levels who they do endure the
pain and they really like the pain and
they will allow that all the day long
they'll allow that now because they'll
tell their brain this is what's expected
but they also don't let themselves feel
good when feeling good is there this is
a real big problem I mean if you study
like psychosis a lot of people who
really struggle with addictions
um Eating Disorders are super common who
even when they feel that sense of
self-love or self-acceptable I'm not
supposed to feel that no you really
there is an element
to personal development where you have
to allow the good feelings and not push
them away because it's like well I
should I don't deserve to feel that
because a huge part of the world is
telling themselves I don't yet deserve
to feel happy
even though happiness comes up I
shouldn't feel that yet I'm going to
keep striving it's not until I get the
next 2 million then I'll let myself feel
happy even though they had that good
Monday
and so you have a lot of people who are
striving in difficulty who also have not
taught themselves the emotional side
of what is called the most important
movement in the history of the world in
Psychology called positive psychology
kicked off by Marty Seligman a good
friend of mine Haley she sent me high
without that work of saying no no we
also have to allow ourselves and teach
ourselves to flourish feel satisfaction
feel Joy so I'm a hundred percent with
you and I'm like the rule is that's one
side of the coin
and the other rule is make sure you
teach yourself
to generate the positive emotions
because what happens is if you don't
teach yourself to generate the positive
emotions as well then what ends up
happening is you burn out or you become
a cliche of the person who had it all
and never felt fulfilled think of your
life
as being a productively fulfilling life
that productivity is not a time
management thing
it's a purpose thing
I don't think of time management when I
think of productivity I think of purpose
I think of who do I want to be what do I
want to contribute
what will be fulfilling for me
because if you don't have something
bigger than just blocks of time which
are important
but there's not something that we
together are going towards where it's
this set of Dreams where there's
personal meaning and there is social
contribution
we won't go the first lesson today in
about sort of having patience for your
dream is you have to work on it every
single day for at least 30 minutes or
don't fool yourself that it's going to
happen
you know we all hope that one day we'll
get a bunch of free weekends or a month
off or three months off and that's when
we'll finally start working towards our
thing you got to do it every day where
that means you research every day you
read every day you study every day you
take a course every day or you actually
create everything on that thing every
day you're just working at it book
authors they write every day not all of
them but a lot of the greats wrote every
single day right and it's just forcing
ourselves
to really be in the game now not
everybody writes every day not everyone
needs to create every day some people
can just have a marvelous 18 days when
they've written the greatest book of all
time but that rarely happens it rarely
happens and those folks tend to be like
Masters or savants or Geniuses regular
folks myself included I gotta work every
day towards my dreams every day I honed
in something about this and if you
didn't know something about me I do
everything in this business right I'm
shooting this video right now but I mean
I picked the materials for this thing I
chose the fonts I designed all the pages
I mean I wrote the back cover the front
cover the inside stuff is like I do the
projects of my dreams let go of the
baggage
you're never going to touch the full rim
of your potential if you're weighted
down by baggage from your Elementary
School years your high school years your
college Years these last four years
listen the last chapters of the book
you've gone through them you finished
them you flip the page you got a new
chapter here
and you have to be willing to break from
the past to have the future you so
desperately desire
you have to have the courage to allow
yourself
to honor the past as it was
to forgive those who need to be forgiven
to forgive yourself
and to acknowledge that everything LED
you to this point now
everything
those crappy times those times when
you're depressed those times when you
gave up on yourself those times when
someone else gave up on you those times
that you gave up on others the times
that you quit the times that you failed
the times that you felt so small you
were embarrassed
those times don't live in this moment
and the more of those times that you
cultivate in your mind and you ruminate
on and you think and you self-talk on
and you revisit in your mind the more
disempowering times from the past
hurtful times from the past
failures from the past that you keep
running in your head what that is doing
is that is taking up the very free space
necessary for the Bold ideas to come in
it's taking up the space for the very
needed white space for creativity to
come in for the dreams to come in for
the best you to speak through from
like it's hard for you to live an
authentic and true and vulnerable in
real life if you're always speaking
through your baggage if you're always
thinking through your baggage and you
guys know what I'm talking about like
everyone's got different baggage Mega
you're maybe maybe your baggage is your
divorce or that last job they are not
relevant today
and the only reason they're relevant
today is If either you allow them to be
relevant from those situations or those
persons revisiting you or you're running
the same old story
you're running the same old excuses yeah
I can't do this because I suck at
relationships no you suck at
relationships 10 years ago well I can't
do this because you know uh I I failed
yeah six months ago today's a new day
homie like you gotta access this day
dude this day is fresh this day is clean
this day woke up showered ready prepped
for you by the universe or Spirit or God
or luck or Cosmos whatever you want to
call it this day
says to you when you wake up in the
morning the day Whispers to you do not
fear me for I have been brought here for
you
you don't fear the day
that day's been brought here for you you
never know a person if you don't know
their goals and if you don't know their
goals you're never going to be a great
friend you'll never be their great lover
their great supporter their great family
member and it's weird though because
most people actually don't know other
people's goals I'll ask family members
to say what what's your sister's goals
you know she wants to be a dancer okay
what kind of dancer when what does she
want to do with that career is the short
term is it long-term like you have to
really get into people's goals to
understand their heart
and so that's what I want you to do is
if you want to be a great spouse to
somebody you got to re-engage and say
hey what do you want at this stage of
your life because I know I know you used
to one then we had kids but where are
you at now and you are getting that
conversation with your partner and say
Hey listen I know we've been through a
couple of weird months where we just
haven't really felt each other out it's
like let's just do some personal
development like what do you really want
to do right now at this stage of your
life because you have to understand when
I say this stage of your life that's
very specific
meaning a lot of people's goals change
and it changes like every three months
every year every three years so if you
haven't had the conversation with the
important people in your life recently
about what your goals are and about what
their goals are then I'm telling you
you're just skimming at the surface
because if you don't support other
people's dreams how can you ever have a
deep relationship with them and if you
don't share your dreams and your heart
and your desire with other people how
could they possibly help you meet that
hunger how can they possibly help you
become the best version of you if you
haven't shared so you also have to be
very honest with what's your real
thoughts what's your real feelings
what's your real dreams what do you
really want at this stage of your life
with all the important people around you
it's one of my favorite things to do
with high performers to say okay do all
the people around you know what you
really want right now are they clear on
what your goals are are they clear about
how they can support that or how much
you want to be involved in it it's like
a lot of people start their own business
but they don't tell the other people
around them what that business is what
it requires how they love their support
and so we all go it alone and isn't
going it alone the opposite of having
healthy supportive relationships
so first thing you gotta do if you want
better relationships get to know other
people's goals many of you you've been
waiting to hire that first virtual
assistant
or that person to help you with the
house so you can focus on your business
who can support you with the kids or
somebody who can you know come in and
help just clean the house some even
waiting to hire that manager that CEO
that CEO and I'm here to tell you do it
like set your quarter one goals of 2019
to hire the team that you need don't
finish quarter one without the team that
you need in place trained and going for
some of you that might be a hundred
employees some of you that's 10 I don't
know what your situation is but I'm here
to tell you higher sooner higher better
if you want to deal with self-doubt you
absolutely must start entering each day
as more intentional of a human because
the issue is one of the reasons we doubt
ourselves is because we're just all over
the place you know sometimes you're cool
in this situation but you're dumb in
that situation sometimes you don't do
well here but you do well here and what
happens is so many people they're going
through the motions or they're just
showing up in life every single day and
they're reacting and because they're
always reacting they don't have a
character
they haven't determined who am I really
who am I going to act like in this
situation who I'm going to behave like
in this situation how I'm going to treat
people in this situation because they
haven't shown up intentional enough and
sought to live out that intention they
feel a lot of Discord in life like they
don't know who they are because they
just keep showing up and reacting to
what's there but guess what what's there
is always different the world is always
changing people are always changing
situations they're always changing so if
all you're ever doing is showing up and
reacting I guess I'll just go through it
and see how it goes you're never forming
an intentional character so of course
you doubt yourself because every
situation is different and you can never
have certainty in that but you can have
strength inside if from now on you wake
up every day and you say okay I'm gonna
be these three words today and you just
set the words you say okay I'm gonna be
fun I'm going to be playful I'm gonna be
kind and that day you are fun playful
and kind and the next day you say okay
I'm gonna be patient today I'm going to
be thoughtful and I'm gonna be
appreciative and you're patient
thoughtful unappreciative you do that
over and over and over again set
intention for who to be be that set an
intention be that set an intention be
that and you do that in more situations
in your life and more days and more
weeks and more months and more years and
one day you wake up and you're like
you're confident in self because you
know that you can direct your mind and
your emotions and your body to be the
person who you really want to be the
more often you do that the more real
genuine self-confidence will come into
your life the most important thing I
know this sounds so so silly but common
sense is not always common practice and
that's why so many potentially great
people fail to ever achieve their
potential and that's this listen you
have to get your visualization game down
visualization that means listen when I
wake up when I got a dream I wake up in
the morning before I go to bed I close
my eyes I just see it happening a little
bit and I'll lay in bed and let my mind
and my body stir up a little bit of
excitement or sometimes even anxiety
about seeing the actual thing that I
want happen that was for me at one part
of my life seeing myself on stages
speaking and training to people one part
of my life it was seeing my book come
out and seeing it on the New York Times
bestseller list or seeing it on the
Amazon bestseller list it was sometimes
seeing myself coaching major celebrities
or sitting side by side with an Oprah
Winfrey or Tony Robbins or Larry King
all of which I've been able to do it was
because I visualized what I really
wanted but here's the thing it's not
just visualization that's like the first
part it's also affect
we talk about high performance and in
Psychology about this thing called
affect which is basically feelings and
emotions I I want you to allow yourself
to literally not just kind of casually
see it like put yourself there and feel
it and sense it and see and feel it and
drink it in like really take in the
Ambiance the circumstances like really
visualize and feel what you are seeing
that's so key I mean as silly as this is
I literally would lay there and I'm like
okay if I'm gonna feel like feel like
feel out the ideal
what questions would I ask to really get
going on I just start literally seeing
myself at my desk in the morning feeling
filling out the high performance planner
thinking about other people worldwide
filling out at the same time as me and
knowing that I got this tribe of people
on this path of trying to be their best
with me and imagining people coming up
because oh my gosh but you know Brandon
you completely changed my morning you
completely changed my weekly routine you
completely changed my life because I'd
never tracked my habits before I'd never
assessed my balance every single week
between family friends work finances
adventure learning Etc everything every
tool that we put in here I could just
imagine someone saying Brandon I really
appreciate that part and I literally
just thought about it because I wanted
it to feel like you know I was excited
for the project otherwise what look how
easy it is to diminish anything in our
lives well it's just a book it's just a
planner it's just a it's just a video
it's just a cosmetic line it's just a
beauty thing it's just that like we all
diminish our dreams we make excuses and
we make our dreams like ah we throw it
away because we're scared to feel it you
know what I'm saying it's easier to
throw it away that's no big deal avoid
it not no problem
and we mess up
I want you to feel it stop detaching
from your dreams
stop avoiding that anxious scary feeling
of thinking how hard it's going to be
and thinking how great it's going to be
because most people just they don't even
think about it because it causes too
much nerves I'm like dancing those
nerves a little bit let them come up for
you because that's fuel man that's fuel
it's like less brown Todds you gotta be
hungry you'll never be hungry if you
don't visualize it see it feel it and
want it I've always really worked
extremely hard to maintain an incredible
level of energy in my mental body my I'm
sorry in my you know mental emotional
physical spiritual being just trying to
do everything I can from the way that I
work out to what I consume to what I
don't consume to how I rest to how I
meditate to how I recover like
everything in my life has always been
about how do I bring the joy and if I'm
going to generate the energy I want to
create for you guys how do I do that
specifically well I've always got these
routines and everything else but what
happened this year I was kind of had my
health taken away a little bit in mid uh
October I got pneumonia yeah and
tonsillitis at the same time while I was
on the road doing multiple four day and
multiple five-day events where I'm kind
of the lead trainer and that
kicked my butt and I'm still honestly
recovering from it like I'm I'm still
feeling it I'm still feeling heading
into the final part of this year I'm
still recovering uh don't worry clean
bill of health doctor's like you're good
to go they're just your body's gonna be
recovering and be tired for a while and
I made it 41 42 years without feeling
fatigue outside of times of injury you
know I I don't think I've ever had the
flu I don't really ever get sick uh when
I get sick it's like sniffles
um but this one was something it just
smacked me I mean I was down and out
that's why I feel like I'm way behind on
my episodes for you all
um it's why I feel like we're launching
a few things in January that I'd hope to
launch in you know October so that like
taking care of my health is always been
a priority this year
I learned what it feels like when it's
gone
and many been with me for a long time
that happened in 2011 when I had my
brain injury and I snapped my wrists and
my ribs and my hip
um so I'm not you know new to pain I'm
not new to being sick but this was the
first time where I also with the
sickness lost motivation
you know where it was like even when I
had like when I was really sick in the
past of my life I would still like wake
up in the day and I'd Prime my mind get
excited about what's to come and just go
this year there was about the last two
months I really had to work on them
there were plenty of days I was just
like Ugh not because I didn't love my
life or I wasn't grateful or present
you've been there before like when you
just you physically feel terrible it is
hard to get your mind right A lot of
people have self-doubt in their lives
because they don't have Clarity for what
they want
a lot of people wander in a situation
and they have a lot of self-doubt
because they didn't sit down and plan it
out they didn't prepare they didn't ask
mentors or model others or do the
research to figure out okay I should do
a b c d and e in other words if you
don't know the steps to success of
course you'll have more self-doubt if
you don't have the plan if you don't
have the map if you don't know what
you're doing of course you're going to
have more self-doubt so part of it is
just like decide to build a plan even if
you have to ask for help and say hey
guys how would you do this what would be
your first step what would be your
second step I'm always asking that even
at this stage of my career I'm still
saying hey guys if you're going to
launch this how would you do it if
you're going to promote that how would
you do it if you're going to create this
thing how would you do it if you're
going to build this team or build that
business what would you do and I always
try to get the map before I enter the
woods so that I have the steps I know
the path because if you can remove the
doubt about the path you'll have more
confidence in yourself because you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
if you want another amazing Brand number
started video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there